i can ask you about something that
i truly enjoy and i think is really
powerful but most people don't seem to
believe in that but it's drilling
i don't know maybe people are different
but i love the idea
maybe even outside of jiu jitsu of doing
the same thing over and over
it's like jiro dreams of sushi i love
doing the thing uh that
nobody wants to do in doing it 10 times
100 times thousand times more than
what nobody wants to do um so
i'm a huge fan of drilling obviously i'm
not a professional athlete but i feel
like if i actually gave myself
if i wanted to be really good at jiu
jitsu like reach the level of being in
the top 25
when i was much younger like really
strive
i think i could achieve it by drilling
that's i had this belief untested can
you challenge this idea
or or first off fascinating
however we're going to have to disagree
no no
okay um we're just going to have to
start to understand
what are we talking about when we talk
about drilling it's a very vague term
okay if you're at this moment many of
your listeners are probably saying
having the same thought process which is
oh drilling yeah i know what that is
we go into the gym and we pick a move
and we practice it for a certain number
of repetitions
and if i do that i'm going to get better
at the technique
okay
they're wrong
we've got to have a much more
in-depth understanding
of what the hell we're talking about
when we talk about drilling
ultimately any movement
in the gym that doesn't
improve the skills you already have or
build new skills
is a waste of time a waste of resources
everything you do should be done with
the aim
and the understanding that this is going
to make me better at the sport i
practice
if it's not it shouldn't be there
the majority of what passes for drilling
in most training halls will not make you
better
including some of the most cherished
forms of drilling
which is repetition for numbers
the moment you say to someone i want you
to do this 100 times
what are they really thinking about
volume
they're saying okay i'm at repetition 78
i'm at 80 20 more to go oh they're
talking their primary thought process
is on numbers that's not the point of
drilling
the point is skill acquisition
when people drill don't get them focused
on numbers get them focused on mechanics
that's what they have to worry about i
never have my students drill for numbers
ever
just you know one truth or get the [ __ ]
out of here
are you kidding me like how are you
gonna get better with that okay
get them working on the sense of gaining
knowledge
that's my job i have to give them
knowledge i have to explain to them
what they're trying to do that starts
them on the right track
but knowledge is one thing skill
is another if jiu jitsu was just about
knowledge
then all the 60 and 70 year old
red balance would be the world champions
they're not judith
isn't one by knowledge it's one by skill
knowledge is the first
step in building skill so my job as a
coach is to transmit
knowledge then i have to create training
programs
where the path from knowledge to
polished
skill is carried out
that's the interface between me and my
students and so i give them
drills where the whole emphasis
is upon getting a sense where they
understand what are the problems they're
trying to solve
and working towards practical solutions
they never work with numbers they work
with
mechanics and feel then
you have to bring in the idea of
progression
when you drill there's zero resistance
when you fight in competition there's a
hundred percent resistance
you can't go from zero to a hundred
there has to be progress over time
where i have them work in drills
with slightly increasing increments
of resistance and just as we talked
about earlier with the weight lifter who
doesn't start with 500 pounds
but who begins with the bar and then
over time builds the skills that one day
out there in the future he will lift 500
pounds
so too that judy gatami that you're
working on today is feeble and pathetic
but five years from now you'll win a
world championship with it
you can't have this naive idea of
drilling it's something you just come
out
you randomly pick a move and you
work for numbers until you satisfy a
certain set of numbers that your coach
threw at you and then think you're going
to get better
there's even dangers with drilling
there is no performance increase
that comes once you get to a certain
level
and you just keep doing the same damn
thing
let's say for example you come out
and you hit a hundred repetitions of the
arm by judy katami from guard position
and you're all proud of yourself because
you hit 100 repetitions and your body's
tired and you're telling yourself
man i got a good workout and you come in
tomorrow
you do exactly the same thing you come
in the day after that
a week goes by and you've done the same
thing
then a year later you do the same thing
ask yourself has your judy katami really
gotten better
no you've performed literally thousands
and thousands of repetitions
you have spent an enormous amount of
training
time and energy that could have gone in
different directions on something which
didn't make you any better
drills have diminishing returns
once you get to a certain skill level if
you just keep hammering on the same
thing
in the same fashion for the same amount
of time
you stop getting better can i partially
for fun partially for dallas advocate
but partially because i actually believe
this to push back on some points
is it possible so everything you said i
think is
beautiful and correct but
the asking yourself the question am i
getting better is a really important one
you could do that in training is there a
set of techniques
maybe a small subset of all the
techniques that are in jiu jitsu
where you can have significant
skill acquisition if you put in the
numbers
or the time whatever on a technique
against an opponent who's
not resisting here's let me elaborate
what i've in my maybe i'm different
you'll probably have to finish an
example
yes let me first make a general
statement and i can give examples
the general statement is i found that
through repetitions
and this is high repetitions combined
with training but high repetitions
against a non-resisting opponent
i've gotten to understand the way my
body moves
the way i apply pressure on a human
because it's not actually zero
resistance the opponent's still laying
there
they're still keeping their legs up
they're still doing
they might not be resisting but they're
still creating a structure
is not a non-dynamic representing a
target
yes it's not dynamic so you can't
master the timing of things but you can
master
the not master but i felt like i could
gain
an understanding of how to apply
pressure to the human body
over thousands of repetitions now for
example i
just just to give you an example to know
what we're talking about
uh there's a guy named uh like sal
hibero and
sean g hebero that have this i guess the
uh
i already forgot but the headquarters
position or something like that
but putting pressure as you pass guard
uh like medium passing distance kind of
pressure
i've did thousands of repetitions of
that to understand
what what putting pressure with my hips
feels like
to truly understand that movement i felt
like i was getting
much better it's like it's hard to put
into words but that skill acquisition is
it's so subtle just the way you turn
your little like hips
but you're already talking about a
better form of drawing now you're
you're going beyond the basic numbers
and you're getting the sense of feel and
mechanics which is what we want
in drilling but the reason i say numbers
and maybe you can speak to this but the
this might be an ocd thing but it it
allows you to take a journey
that doesn't just last a week or two
weeks
but a journey where you stay with the
technique for two
three years and there's a dedication to
it
where it's a long-term commitment
to where you're forcing yourself that
perhaps there's other mechanisms but
you're forcing yourself to stay with a
technique longer than most people around
you are staying with whatever they're
working on
and you're taking that long journey and
the numbers somehow
enforce that persistence and that
dedication
um first thing that journey is
a wonderful thing and if that technique
is a
a crucial part of what you do then it's
time well invested
but always understand that it comes at
an opportunity cost that
by spending that amount of time on that
one technique you've sacrificed other
things that you could have
learned that could have won you matches
so understand that every
focus upon one element of the game comes
at the opportunity cost of other
elements
um now as long as you're playing a part
of the game where
okay this is central to what i do yes
okay that's fine
but um just be aware of the danger of
opportunity cost that's something no one
talks about in the training room but
it becomes very important secondly the
other question you have to start asking
yourself is
okay that training clearly had benefits
for you
early on but when the point of
diminishing return starts coming and if
you feel you're just doing the same
thing then it's time to switch now if
you
feel you're still getting benefit from
it by all means continue
that will be a call on your part you're
you've been playing this game a long
time now so
i would trust your call on that um uh
but my job as a coach is to look out and
say
okay this kid's been working across
hashigorami
for six months and i feel he's gotten to
a good skill level
if he stays any further on it the
opportunity cost
becomes greater than the expected
benefits of continuing
it and that's my job as a coach is to
direct things in that fashion if i can
do a good job with that
then i can take them to the next level
of drilling and
start amping it up and that's how i keep
progress over time
my biggest fear is to have students
run past the point of diminishing
returns staying stagnant
where opportunity cost comes in and
they're not making the progress they
could in the time that they've been
working
i mean that was it was almost a
philosophical question for me
that's what i was always in a search on
because i know my mind
is uh likes drilling i don't like
relying on other people
for improvement and drilling
allows me to do something that that
that is hundred percent interesting like
you say you don't like relying on other
people and drilling but in drilling
you really do rely a lot on your partner
one of the first things i do when i
coach people is i teach them how to
drill
i that's a skill in itself and
is in drilling sense the opposite of
sparring drilling is a cooperative
venture
where you work as dance partners
complementing each other's movement
if i drill with gordon ryan and i want
him to work armbars i will move my body
in ways which
make it an interesting exercise for
gordon
um i'm not just sitting there and he
does a repetition and i'm
okay he does 10. um i can't wait for
this to be over so i can do my 10 and i
can't wait for all the spears so we can
just spar
and get over with all this [ __ ] um
that's the sad truth of most
drilling and jujitsu um
there's a sense in which when good
people drill it's like watching
good people dance they move in unison
and complement each other's movement and
make each other look better
um sparring on the other hand is the
exact opposite of that that's
resistance where you're trying to make
the other person look as bad as possible
and once you understand the different
directions in which drilling and
sparring go
that's when things start getting
interesting you start getting fast
progress
yeah just uh you're absolutely right i i
think i was
not very eloquent describing what i mean
i found myself
not able to find and just with too many
people that are willing
to dedicate a huge amount of time to a
particular technique
i concur with you on netflix now answer
the interesting question
why why can't you get people to drill
with you
by the way if i could just shout out the
people that did draw with me
is usually blue belt women
because they're smaller they don't like
training
because they get their ass kicked
because they're much smaller
so they're willing to improve it invest
a significant amount of effort into uh
um
into training that's that's good but
their motivation for doing so is not
good
well yes but your motivation for
drilling is because you don't want to
get your ass kicked
no good felt ever i could never find a
black belt that i could draw with like
this
this the uh now let's go back to that
question why
i don't i mean this i i am
somebody who likes to say nice things
about people so let me let me answer for
you yeah
two reasons because they find it boring
yes and secondly
perhaps more importantly they don't
believe it works yeah
those are good answers and now let's go
further and ask the truly interesting
question
why do they believe that
if i were to answer it in the context of
russian wrestling where drilling is much
bigger part is i think culturally
that was knowledge that everybody tells
each other
in jiu jitsu that drilling
doesn't work because they're never
taught how to drill
no one ever sits you down one day and
says okay this is how you drill
and so the exercise feels futile they
don't feel the skill level is going up
they don't associate drilling with
increased skill level they associate
sparring with increased
skill level but not drilling which is a
tragedy because it is
a fantastic way to introduce and expand
the repertoire
of a developing student it's an
essential part of every workout i teach
i always say the game of jiu-jitsu
begins with knowledge and
builds up to skill who wins is the one
who has greater skill
and nine times out of ten um so to me
it's a tragedy that
what you're saying breaks my heart to
hear that you couldn't get a black belt
to drill with you that's
that's shameful and i but i understand i
i i sympathize with those black belts
too because
the way in which most people are told to
drill does feel
ineffective and it is damn boring they'd
rather just spar
they feel like they get more out of the
workout and that's
it's if anything an indictment upon most
of the training programs around the
nation
would you say that drilling if you were
to build
a black belt world champion would
drilling be
what percent of their training in the
entirety of their career would be
drilling
good great question um let's first put a
proviso on it that i don't
do the same thing for all athletes
everyone's got a different personality
and uh like nikki rod i can only hold
his attention for two minutes at a time
and uh uh gary tonen
um five minutes uh gordon ryan
five hours like uh george zempier five
hours
travis stevens five hours they'll they
are just
laser focused so everyone's different
let's put that down as our first proviso
um uh you probably knew those answers
already yeah
um that's hilarious but
as a general rule uh if i run
a two and a half hour class uh
you can expect an hour and a half of it
to be
i'm going to use the word drilling but
i'm also going to say that
this is too complex of a story to give
now with words i would need to
demonstrate it
but the way in which we drill is not
your standard method of drilling
and then it's inspiring
but if you give me a choice between a
bad drilling partner and sparring
i could make the same choice that most
black belts make because i'd go with
sparring
because you can create drilling with the
things within the aspiring environment
like good drilling is a wonderful thing
bad drilling is just a worthless waste
of time
you